darf ich hab's anfangen dafür einfach
anders anfangen fällig
herzlich willkommen zurück in der tasche
und ich bin immer noch auf dem weg auf
der suche nach gewählt und dahin mit der
nord und der will sein
ich habe zwei stadt gefahren ich habe
hier irgendwie ist glaube ich irgendwann
du wolltest von mir irgendwas willst du
wolltest nethery kam da ist es wieder
und du luca volt ist glaube ich nee du
hast eine spinne getötet polit aufnahmen
gstadt hast und ich hab xp bekommen so
war das irgendwas war da doch damit sind
wieder neuen folge und es geht weiter
ich brauche übrigens noch 23
bücherregale
dafür muss jetzt erst mal sinken gehen
aber wir gehen direkt weiter mit dem
thema weil es sind songs portal gegangen
jahr räder du einfach mal weiter der
karte gegen dornhan dazu was sagen was
sehr interessantes totenmaske gast das
thema sind youtube netzwerke inhalt auf
einmal alle kräfte
ich hab nichts geklaut ernsthaft nicht
ich weiß du hast du bist ja ich hab kein
netz also was ich ja zu meiner netzwerke
denkt blabla also erstmal das kommando
kicker dann ist man gesagt hat dass mir
ein gewerbe anmelden muss und alles
mögliche der spieler mal gar nicht das
wird auch selber wieder ein gutes video
geladen
velen pd auf dem kanal einfach bewerbe
suchen bewertete partners aber das ist
jetzt erst mal auf so jedenfalls ich bin
zurzeit in gar keinem netzwerk ich war
auch neben den netzwerken zweimal kurz
davor netzwerk zu gehen aber das war
eigentlich dann irgendwie scheiße ich
habe die volle zeit getötet hat sich das
egal
die vorletzte wir haben nur eine
wieso hast du den dahin gesetzt weil ich
wollte erstmal kurz ich hab ja nur einen
stapel 14 stück habe ich ja aber dann ob
irgendwas haben passt für dich nur weiß
langsam aufzubauen
was macht er denn hier alles voll bei
mir ganz am anfang ich bin ja noch einer
der glücklichen geht das überhaupt zeit
noch dass ich gar nicht dass man sich
somit mit youtube partnern kann das habe
ich nämlich damals gemacht das ging aber
damals nur wenn man wirklich alle rechte
an den spielen hatte und damals was so e
mail schweren welches spielrechte dran
zu kommen weil die spieleindustrie da
doch gar nicht so spielen wollt wird
falls ich rät jetzt rat von vor einem
jahr ungefähr wo ich angefangen hatte
bin 2000 oder so bin ich partner
geworden bei youtube war das dann erst
dann erstmal minecraft htc und mit der
zeit wollte ich dann aber auch andere
games machen nur dann braucht man dafür
natürlich lizenzen ich mir gedacht okay
wir sind ihr soviel netzwerke die gm
derzeit die großen sag ich mal
gamestar hatte zu dem zeitpunkt auf
30.000 nennt und auch die webseite noch
nicht so bekannt vor einem jahr wie sie
jetzt auf die zeitschrift ist er
mittlerweile sehr sehr im handel
erhältlich überall keine
seinerzeit war die zeit wirklich für
viel erfolgreicher als wird nach
hallenberg aufschrift wird allgemein
mittlerweile sind die gamestar war doch
eigentlich früher noch viel bekannt
hätte ich jetzt mehr so gedacht die
haben ja auch schon diese kommentierten
videospiel videos gemacht bevor es dem
begriff let's play überhaupt aprilia
schon ein spiel gespielt haben
also ich meine schon vor zehn jahren und
zahlt das damals kannten so was von
wenig leute gamestar
das war einfach so weil damals als
franck war ja als youtube hat damals
auch noch gar kein ja das meine ich ja
gerade krank war damals noch gar kein
partner und die ganzen anderen als auch
egal jedenfalls wollte ich dann auf
jeden fall zu maschine immer geben weil
die da gerade so ein geiles video
hochgeladen haben von wegen wir nehmen
deutsche leute an und kommen in unser
netzwerk und sendet einmal dein content
da dachte ich mir so kay machst einmal
einfach eine schnapsidee habe ich dann
gemacht und berlin
also die kamen dann an jahr mindestens
100 abonnenten und ich hatte dann
irgendwie 2000 als ob das eine
eingesendeten so japans durch zu uns
kommen
ich habe mir dann erst mal den vertrag
von den zusenden lassen hab in meinem
vater beziehungsweise unserem steuer
fritzlar gegeben jetzt den durchgegangen
hat gesagt wie ich nicht hingehen und
weil er halt so ein paar klauseln drin
waren von wegen ja wenn mich als
unterschreibe dann ist der dichter 22
jahre verpflichtet und habe dann das
gleiche gehalt und blau und das gleiche
dann eigentlich auch bei tgm vor allem
innovativen was wenn jetzt in letzter
zeit so die spam nicht einfach zu die
haben mich bei twitter dreimal gefragt
ihr per mail mit der c e mails gesendet
und bei youtube ich hab die blockiert
damit die mich nicht weiter zu spannen
von wegen hey computing also die nsm
somit ist unseriös und bescheuert einmal
was ich kenne in serie
er sei also erwarte dass wir da erst mal
ausreden man das war schon so ich habe
eine kleine steine fällt noch auf jeden
fall
war ich dann halt so von wegen gamestar
können wir auch mal nachfragen ja
vielleicht annehmen und dann war das
zufällig grad die zeit modena wird diese
let's play woche der stattgefunden hat
oder hattest du ja mit pete glaube ich
dann was aufgenommen und dann ihr
wolltet mich sondern irgendwie hätten
deswegen hast du ihn an mich
weitergeleitet und so bla bla bla bla
bla wir haben uns dann unterhalten
darüber und so weiter und so fort also
ich mit pete von beats mit events
gartenschlauch steht oder so und der hat
mir dann auch ein vertrag zugesendet und
da dachte ich dann eigentlich hin zu
gehen vor allem weil ich da auch schon
ab 16 hin durfte und ich war halt da mit
16 oder 15 sogar noch oder 16 ich weiß
es nicht jedenfalls habe ich bis heute
wollt wenn du weißt was du geburtstag
hast wirst du ein bisschen kalt wie hab
ich weiß nicht in welchem monat das war
2000 februar oder märz
ja deswegen ich werde im februar 16 17
wasser auf der schwelle 15 16
ja irgendwie so jedenfalls suche ist
dann sahin
aber dann habe ich mir gedacht nee lukas
du leistest du versuchst unabhängig zu
bleiben ich weiß zwar nicht was es
damals was mir dabei gedacht habe aber
egal habe ich dann jedenfalls gesagt
okay ich gehe doch nicht nicht alex mit
blabla und dann war ich jetzt erstmal
die komplette zeitlich unabhängig waren
gar keinem netzwerk bin auch in gar
keinem netzwerk und ich bin eigentlich
recht zufrieden vor allem weil wenn man
lizenzen haben möchte kann man ja immer
den entwickler einfach per mail
anschreiben vor allem weil es ist sehr
geil gelöst muss echt sagen
der nämlich eine liste
von deutschen leuten bei denen die in
der kategorie pr und marketing arbeiten
und da kann man sich dann das steht
eigentlich fünf verschiedene
e-mail-adressen von leuten dafür
zuständig sind habe ich dann so einen
oliver krause keine ahnung wieder hieß
angeschrieben findet ihr auch als bei
denen vor bei einem langen text ob er
mit den lizenzen geben könnte da meinte
der ja machen wir zwar nicht so häufig
aber hier und jetzt habe ich zum
beispiel die lizenz in allen ea spielen
von cablecom auch zur monetarisierung
des lizenz- und das sind unter anderem
halt battlefield fifa simcity und das
wird geil ich hoffe ich darf sollte zwar
kein deutsch
naja jedenfalls gibt es irgendwas zu
unseriösen netzwerken sagen aber ich
glaube sehr gespannt du hast ja gesagt
das t-shirt über das unseriös netzwerke
überhaupt ist und da wollte ich nur kurz
weil ja ich habe nicht gesagt dass
sachsen dann sagen jetzt viele gäste
schon der kontrakt hat gesagt gtl ist
unseriöse überhaupt das was man so hört
sie sind nicht und sie meine commander
krieger hat ja sogar song hate video
gegen sein damaliges netzwerk gemacht
das war aber nicht denn ich finde man
sollte vorsichtig mit sowas sein weil
halt viele leute sondern einfach nach
sagen und dann sowas ist hofmann sogar
glauben ja ja wenn das ist so echt ruf -
was machst wenn du sagst chen ist das
ganze ist eine heilung behaupte es ist
eine ganz einfache meinung du hast auch
vorhin gesagt dass
galileo kompletten du zweifelst an
diesen sachen die sie da machen und
blablabla das ist dann kein rohes als
wenn du da wird man doch sagen
die gns das unseriös ich hab es übrigens
gar nicht gesagt das ist das unseriös
ich habe gesagt ich finde ihn einfach
nur bescheuert und das ist meine meinung
könnte der kontrast ist gesagt ist oder
nicht
aber das ist ja auch ich meine jetzt
nicht dass jetzt hierfür in den knast
kommt das rad nur dass es liegt ansicht
ansicht grenzt schon an rufmord wenn er
sagt es unseriös ist bei uns seriös dass
man mit ihnen keine geschäfte machen
soll das macht deren geschäft kaputt
damit haben sie ein riesenschaden und
das ist rufmord
so aber davon mal ganz abgesehen etienne
ist jetzt einfach zu viel gewachsen und
die haben nicht genug mitarbeiter sind
wahrscheinlich auch nicht profitabel
also das unternehmen die ändern sich
macht keinen gewinn
ein großes problem und deswegen hat man
da als partner schlechten in support
gehabt so scheint es jetzt aussieht
stehen
nein da niemanden kein gewinn hier noch
ein video gemacht dass diese dass sie
von ihrer mutter firma sozusagen sieht
ja gar kein eigenes youtube netzwerk
sondern nur ein unter netzwerk von
broadband tv und broadband tv bezahlt im
moment alles was die un hat weil die tat
selber gar keine eingaben und weil alles
was die channel partner bekommen ist das
gleiche was broadband das team von
broadway weil komplizierte sache was
wahrscheinlich geht es jetzt los es ist
kein besonders unseriöses unternehmen
das wollte ich nur noch mal sagen aber
es gibt viele youtube netzwerken da
musst du aufpassen die unseriös sind
wer auf jeden fall nicht dazu gehört
sind zum beispiel leben gamestar
software spinne oder auch media kraft
oder was es sonst vergeht oder major
studios die waren jetzt auch ganz groß
in der kritik weil die mit ray johnson
den vertrag hat mich hier raus wollte
und die wollen ihn behalten und dann
gab's den großen crash und die einen und
der vertrag war sein vertrag war so und
dann haben sie über twitter beef gehabt
haben sich andere große youtube
eingeschaltetes war schon recht amüsant
aber an sich sie die auch seriös und es
gibt ja auch noch was
gaming cards sind also ganz ganz kleine
in label network gibt es glaube ich auch
schon ganz kleinlaut und soweit ich
weiss auch seriös aber es gibt halt
endlich nicht aber es gibt halt einfach
seine netzwerke die auf jeden fall wo
man halt aufpassen wasser da aber in
netzwerken form an irgend vertrag
unterschreibt immer da erst mal ganz
genau durch den wiederum koste das er
gemacht hat wieder uns gesagt hat
bevor man irgendwas unterschreibt bei
man sich teilweise auch für zwei jahre
verpflichtet die games des vertrags
obwohl das opfer sagen er ist relativ
relativ ich sag mal klein vergleich zu
zum beispiel maschinen damit habe ich an
verschiedenen arten bekannt für
knebelverträge wurde sein
das war früher so jetzt nicht mehr aber
die ersten verträge wand wirklich
lebenslänglich wenn dann hat auch in
youtuber gesagt dass er daraus folgte
und ein ganz ganz großen aufstand
youtube gemeinde gleich der erste große
fall
und ja seitdem ist mir da noch
zweijährig oder siebenjährig das ist
auch ohne schufa 7 bekommt sie ja nicht
gleich jeder denselben vertrag
sondern auch unterschiedlich auch als
kleiner youtuber bekommt ihr sowieso mit
abstand immer die schlechtesten
frankfurt herum
also wenn ihr beim netzwerk sei der
geht's einfach eiskalt da geht es halt
um geld und da muss man natürlich darauf
behandelt sich um zu schauen ob man da
irgendwie was besseres bis ich selbst
aushandeln kann ich werde so lange wie
möglich probieren ohne netzwerk aus
zukunft der vorteil von netzwerk ist
halt dass man hat man dafür nicht darum
darum kümmern muss als setzte sich nicht
darum kümmern ob da irgendwelche rechte
sondern es macht halt das netzwerk für
dich aber was was was für normale sage
ich mal offen gelegte vorteile hat man
dadurch außer jetzt vielleicht ein cross
promoting das in größerer ein video like
das kann ja auch so passieren also ich
meine wenn du kannst ja auch sogar
deswegen deswegen ist es auch kein
richtiger vorteil
wie gesagt der größte fall so die bieten
natürlich viele netzwerke ist auch als
unterschiedlich die sagen die halter
wenn er zu uns kommst dann hast du die
und die vorteile und das netzwerk
zuletzt viele sagen die verdienst mehr
geld das ist eigentlich nie der fall
fast nie der fall
aber es muss man sich alles genau
anschauen das ist bei jedem
unterschiedlich oder dass man halt dass
das man promotet wird in irgendeiner
weise aber es ist auch immer von
netzwerk zu netzwerk unterschiedlich und
als letzte natürlich dass die rechte
haben aber ich meine rechte wenn man
wenn man sagen wenn die felder kriegt
man sie auch aber das stimmt natürlich
nicht nur zum beispiel und dass man alle
partner funktionen hat wie du ja schon
gesagt dass also solltet also schwer
richtiger youtube partner zu werden also
mit dem kanal banner oben und das geht
halt nur als wichtiger partner und das
wird bald leichter über netzwerke als
direkte bei youtube
alle netzwerkpartner werden hat man hat
als regierungspartei
man hat auf jeden fall nicht in twann
oben so weit ich weiß hat niemand mehr
doch ich hab den ja dass man den in
einer fähre am kanalweg so ziemlich viel
eigentlich wollte ich sagen bzw
alle sagen ja media kraft hier die
machen ganz youtube schlecht früher war
alles besser und jetzt ist als nur
kommerz und so und youtube zu meedia
kraft ihn wäre total schlecht
weil für mich hat sich jetzt nichts
geändert dass sie bei mir ja kraft wenn
ein anderes unternehmen das was mir mein
youtuber geld auszahlt also ob das jetzt
gamestar de ski die dahinter stellen
oder media kraft und bloß dass ich halt
ein paar andere vertraten anderen
vertrag bei den halt nein klar eine
aufnahme dafür dass sagen wen und wo ich
jetzt drauf hinaus wollte biss banken
mehr geld oder wegen der support beides
beides war okay also bin ich sonst mir
eigentlich wenn ich wenn ich beim
netzwerk das muss einfach bei mir im
hintergrund ist und ich kann mein ding
durchziehen wenn ich mal ein problem
habt kann ich hab ich das schnell in
kontakt und ansonsten natürlich dass es
netzwerk sich nicht übermäßig selbst
viel geld abzwacken als eine sicherheit
für sich ein behält sondern dass ich das
da sich natürlich aus meiner aus meinen
videos natürlich selbst das meiste
bekommen es bringt ja nichts wenn das
netzwerk als mir bringt natürlich nichts
wenn das netzwerk irgendwie da besonders
viel geld raus bekommt und wie einfach
dass ich meine videos einfach machen
kann und dass sie mich nicht um sowas an
kümmern muss worum sie den netzwerk
kümmern können und bei gamestar war das
einfach nicht so ganz gegeben dass ich
mich also hatte ich das gefühl aber das
kann auch für jeden halt anders sein
darum möchte ich da auch kein wirklich
schlecht reden also das muss man immer
für sich selbst sehen schauen und so
weiter dann hab ich würde euch nur
direkt davon abraten zu irgendwelchen
unseriösen netzwerk vergehen vor allem
wenn es irgendwie amerikanisches heißt
natürlich nicht dass alle amerikanischen
netzwerke schlecht finde dass ich
irgendwie schlecht machen will nicht
dass sie das so interpretiert aber auf
jeden fall hinterfragen vertrag genau
durchschauen und besten nicht alleine
sondern mit fahrrad oder mit einer
person die sich damit auskennt seid
vorsichtig schnell das ist ja nicht mehr
so pipifax ist schon das kann schon mal
ganz böse enden und damit endlich diese
volk und wir sind beim nächsten mal
wieder deuce